ah yes
I gotta just start like I heard a
podcast the other day and they were like
saying something about how we have to
remove want if you want to be like Jesus
Jesus or Jesus depending on how much of
a [ __ ] [ __ ] you were some [ __ ]
relax will say Jesus
um but you have to uh remove want from
your vocabulary and your
just you remove want from your life and
I was like man that's like if you didn't
want [ __ ] how much easier your life
would be like I I see shoes sometimes
like I want those but then when I just
sit back and I'm like if I wanted to
remove a want from my life
there you go I already want to remove
one from my life so I'm [ __ ]
I'm thinking of it wrong if I didn't
want let's just say that if I didn't
want
right
then
how easy would Life Begin the the it's
just tremendous but then you have a kid
and you want their life to be good and
that's a want so it's like that's really
false on its ass and religion is
[ __ ] all good but don't be mad at me
if you think you know it's like
I'm not outwardly outspoken against this
[ __ ] but it's just like religion is just
like you know what I mean it's just like
between religion you know they they how
they house a bunch of traditions and
traditions or the start of everything
horrible you know what I say on my
podcast like tradition in my on my in my
cult we have no traditions because
Traditions is what causes War tradition
is what causes anger Traditions is what
makes your dad flip up the [ __ ] plate
on Thanksgiving because it's not going
right and then he's pissed and goes in
his room and they gotta talk if there
were no traditions we would all live in
harmony I'm telling you the truth dude
everyone's [ __ ] crazy religion isn't
saying you know what religion does it
makes people [ __ ] rich but then also
it makes people crazy right so the guy
from Hobby Lobby is not re not leaving
his estate to his children dude he is
not leaving his estate to his children
he's just giving it away dude and if I
was this kid I'd be like oh come on dad
like at least Bill Gates is leaving like
a small amount to his kids which dude
those people are [ __ ] crazy dude man
if I stack
hundreds of millions of dollars if I got
if I got that Hobby Lobby money guess
who's getting all of that yaper dude
Calvin guess who's getting all of that
yaper when I croak all of the people
closest to me dude
nobody else is getting the red scent
even if I start believing dude I could
if I could start believing in all of the
Gods
nobody getting a red scent but my
bloodline dude
nobody's getting a red nobody's getting
a crimson scent dude
I swear to God well what about nope what
about the tithe nope nobody's getting a
red scent unless they got that Delia
name after it and they're younger than
me or if I die prematurely older than me
I swear to God
I'm gonna leave one sent to all my
enemies oh that's [ __ ] cool dude
I'm gonna leave one cent to all my
enemies I gotta write my will
I really do it's been on the back of my
mind
congratulations
[Music]
[Music]